For the first time in Legendary Entertainment's
MonsterVerse, the King of Monsters himself
shares the screen with the Eighth Wonder of
the World in Godzilla vs. Kong.
The fourth epic film in the rebooted franchise
dropped on March 31st, landing both in theaters
and on HBO Max.
As huge as both of these formidable behemoths
of cinema are, the battle between them is
a spectacle to behold no matter the size of
the screen.
Godzilla vs. Kong takes its audience into
a new realm — specifically, Hollow Earth
— along with a group of new characters.
Alexander Skarsgard joins the cast as reclusive
scientist, Nathan Lind, and Rebecca Hall plays
Ilene Andrews, an advocate for King Kong who
will do whatever it takes to ensure his protection.
Millie Bobby Brown returns to reprise her
role as Madison Russell, the young woman who
sets out to prove that Godzilla's motives
for destruction are not what they seem.
This time Madison is joined by her friend
Josh Valentine, played by young Kiwi actor
Julian Dennison.
But Godzilla vs. Kong has more than just new
cast members and a new story — there's also
a nifty new artifact with its own bit of lore
to explore.
This time, Kong has more than his giant fists
to use when pounding away at his enemies,
and we're here to talk about the mysterious
weapon discovered deep within the bowels of
Hollow Earth: King Kong's axe.
It's not as if King Kong really needs a weapon,
given his sheer strength, size, and intimidating
presence.
Yet the filmmakers of Godzilla vs. Kong decided
that the fans needed a new piece of lore to
speculate over, and the axe that appears in
the movie certainly provides one.
Later, inside a grand hall within what appears
to be an ancient castle, Kong finds an axe-shaped
hole in the ground.
As soon as Kong places the axe in its place,
the room begins to light up and the axe starts
to glow.
So just what is this enigmatic weapon, and
what special powers does it have?
Although they are somewhat keeping mum about
the subject, Godzilla vs. Kong's director,
Adam Wingard, and writer, Max Borenstein,
both spoke with Collider to give fans a few
clues.
Wingard hinted,
"Yeah, it's something that we just kind of
tease at in the movie and hopefully we can
explore in later films."
Borenstein elaborated a bit further, suggesting
that the axe was originally fashioned from
the scales of a Godzilla-like creature, which
would perhaps explain how Godzilla was able
to charge up the axe with his atomic breath
at the climax of the film.
The writer also suggested that this axe, in
particular, was likely made just for Kong.
Borenstein said,
"Presumably there are more like it, but it
feels like the iconic scepter of the King."
It certainly stands to reason that the giant,
glowing axe would be a weapon intended for
Kong, rather than a happenstance discovery.
In the movie's mythology, Kong hails from
an ancient and fallen kingdom contained within
the Hollow Earth.
The very fact that the axe was discovered
in this subterranean cavity — and that it
interacts with the ancient castle — suggests
this deadly artifact might have once been
part of the raiments of Kong's station.
We're guessing Borenstein's use of the word
"scepter" is no coincidence.
Borenstein has been one of the main creative
influences in Legendary's MonsterVerse since
the beginning, so if anyone has the long game
in mind, it's him.
Although there may be more axe mythology coming
in later films, it still plays a pivotal role
in the resolution of Godzilla vs. Kong.
The axe is an object that actually unites
the two titular monsters.
It's an artifact from Kong's buried past,
fashioned from the body of Godzilla.
In that way, the axe becomes a symbol of their
alliance to take down Mechagodzilla.
Of course, it's also the literal means of
their salvation; in the climactic battle,
Godzilla "charges" up the axe with nuclear
breath, and Kong swings it for the win.
So when will we get to learn more about the
weapon's origins in the deep recess of MonsterVerse
lore?
That depends on whether or not the studio
decides to make a sequel to Godzilla vs. Kong.
Borenstein told Collider,
"I think the MonsterVerse is at a crossroads
where audiences need to vote that they wanna
see another one of these films before they
continue."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows and movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.